ce serait une deuxième victoire contre
le coran navires us en très peu de temps
la compagnie modern annonce que son
nouveau vaccin aurait un taux
d'efficacité de 94,5 % encore plus élevé
que celui de freezer efficace à 90%
oui bien sûr les résultats sont
préliminaires le vaccin n'est pas encore
approuvé mais à première vue ça semble
très prometteur on s'attendait d'avoir
des résultats relativement élevé du fait
que fraser et moderno utilise des
technologies très semblables mais de
l'autre avoir des niveaux qui atteignent
ou du 90 le suis vraiment sur 20 cas
selon les essais cliniques de moderna le
vaccin immunise rey 19 personnes sur 20
ils seraient particulièrement efficaces
pour protéger aussi bien les jeunes que
les gens âgés et malades
mais pour connaître la durée de la
protection il faudra être patient nous
pensons qu'une protection d'au moins 6
mois devraient être là ce que nous
serons bien sûr dans quelques mois et la
durée de protection à au moins un an
important ce vaccin peut également être
transporté y conserver à des
températures habituelles pour un vaccin
contrairement celui du fraser qu'on doit
maintenir à moins 70 degrés celsius on a
signé des ententes et modern le canada
déjà réservé des doses du vaccin modern
à 56 millions au total qui viennent
s'ajouter aux 60 et 16 millions de doses
réservez auprès de pfizer moderna
prévoit d'en produire entre 500 millions
et 1 milliard d'ici la fin 2021 et comme
d'autres entreprises
elle se prépare aussi à la possibilité
d'avoir un modifier la recette de son
vaccin en fonction de l'évolution de la
pandémie
il ya des jeux de lutte à sion majeurs
qui ont apparu au niveau du crâne au
virus dont une qui a produit des âmes
ton beaucoup plus sévère donc faut
s'assurer que les vaccins vont permettre
de combattre toutes les souches et audi
variant des changements au moins une
dizaine d'autres fabricants sont engagés
dans cette course pour vacciner
l'ensemble de la planète
note un record ici norma grondin radio
canada montréal